begin with chief intelligence
correspondent catherine herridge with a
look at
how investigators got their suspect good
evening katherine thank you brett and
good evening today's announcement is the
culmination of a five-day manhunt that
began monday
in the greater new york area and ended a
thousand miles away in south florida
drawing on more than a dozen federal
agencies led by the secret service and
fbi
we have arrested cesar sayoc in
connection
with this investigation the 56-year-old
suspect was arrested in south florida
and is now facing five federal criminal
counts for sending explosives through
the mail
and targeting current and former
democratic politicians
this is utterly unacceptable political
violence or the threat of violence
is antithetical to our vigorous system
of self-government
federal investigators seized his van
covering it with a blue tarp
concealing pro-trump stickers sayoc
social media accounts also praising
republicans
slamming democrats and showcasing videos
of himself
appearing at trump rallies the attorney
general was pressed on why sayoc singled
out democrats
and at least one powerful party donor he
may have been a part
appears to be a partisan but that would
be determined by the facts
the break in the case came when an fbi
lab identified a latent fingerprint on
one of the suspicious package envelopes
addressed to democratic congresswoman
maxine waters two additional pieces of
dna
evidence from other packages match sayoc
who was already in a law enforcement
database
because of his past criminal activity
the work of the men and women of law
enforcement here and the work
that was done over the last week is
something that should make every
american proud and grateful
another device was discovered today in
california addressed to democratic
senator kamala harris
and in new york city addressed a cnn
contributor and former director of
national intelligence james clapper
the fbi director emphasized the devices
now more than a dozen
intercepted on the east and west coast
were dangerous
not a hoax laying out new details of
their construction
each device consisted of roughly six
inches of pvc pipe
a small clock a battery
some wiring and what is known as
energetic material
a conviction on the five federal
criminal charges which could expand as
the investigation progresses
carries a prison term of up to 48 years
the defendant's
conduct as charged is cowardly and
reprehensible
and totally anathema to our democracy
in the last few minutes we have learned
that sayoc will have his first court
appearance in miami on monday earlier a
federal source told fox
that after that initial court appearance
in miami sayoc is expected to be
transferred
to new york city and prosecuted there
nearly half of the packages were routed
through the greater new york city area
brett katherine the news conference was
pretty detailed
they said that they were still
investigating whether he had any help
when it with anybody else but what else
was kind of left out of that well we
never really got to was the issue of
premeditation was this something that he
did over several weeks himself so making
him a lone actor
in this offense or was it done very
quickly which would suggest that he may
have had help from someone who was
winning or
unwitting in this plot okay catherine
we'll follow it thank you